ich muss echt nächsten tagen nicht dicht
vor der noch unklaren alltag vergisst
was ihr macht nein nein nein nein nein
servus sg zh und herzlich willkommen zur
dritten folge von uc4 legen direkt los
wie es ist wieder der markus dabei hallo
ich bin immer überall wissen gerade so
ein bisschen am vor produzieren und wie
in der letzten folge wie ihr vielleicht
wisst haben uns dieses geile schwer
gemacht dass drei punkte mehr hat als
ein dia schwert also richtig fett und
wir haben uns die ausrüstung machte
schon in der ersten folge und jetzt
achtung special
wir haben uns einen schritt gemacht okay
denn der steht aber richtig schnell
schaden alter das übel kraus er hat
jetzt schon fast wieder die hälfte weg
aber er ist auf jeden fall ultradrive
pvp weil er echt viel der mit wegnimmt
und ja was haben wir uns für die heutige
folge folgen ich habe immer so gedacht
so eine weizen fahren wäre nicht
schlecht
sobald eine ganze legion wer da schon
geil muss
ich überlege gerade mal die hier macht
vielleicht hier direkt hier vorne hin
hast du tomaten ja ich habe vier stück
kann man die pflanzen
dann kann man die pflanzen wie tomaten
ja glaubt schon hatte ich noch arbeiten
muss hat das irgendwo hinter kommentaren
gelesen dass man eine tomate pflanzen
kann
ja wir sollten uns einfach was wir uns
auf jeden fall suchen sollten ist ein
kürbis
man kann nämlich also ich hab mal mit
note die die divine output sachen
durchgeschaut und man kann einfach
man kann einfach einen kürbis in den
backofen packen und hat dann einen ofen
hat dann eine nahrung die fünf punkte
regeneriert einfach so
das ist ultra geil es gibt sogar ist
sachen hier nimmt in dem objekt und ja
wie gesagt es gibt auch noch den donath
den habe ich in der letzten folge
erwähnt der dafür braucht man acht
weizen und ordnet die in so einem kreis
an so als würde man aus holz eine tour
brachten oder aus steinen einen ofen und
dann kriegt man da einen donut raus und
dieser download regeneriert acht hunger
punkte das ist krass ihr müsst euch das
mal geben acht das ist doppelt so viel
wie kürbiskuchen acht doppel sowie viele
yeah
komm mal runter frost will ich boxen die
frost die die schweden auch immer so
dumm rum wenn man die haut genau wie die
places und die schießen ähnlich auch so
sind nun nicht mal ansatzweise so stark
dass man sozusagen die ja ich bin ich
sein
okay aber es wird jetzt schon wieder
nach tirol dessen frost in unsere bude
drin raus da kommt komm raus raus raus
kommt
das ist über das
ich musste ihn von hinten das mitten in
unsere bude drin scheiße scheiße ich
muss dir monaten gestützt
das kind ab alter ich mir vor der jetzt
mit in unsere bude hochgegangen
ach du scheiße
so ich brauche ich jetzt etwa zu ihr
damit wir wieder bisschen ruhe haben wir
können einfach mal eine tür dahin machen
ja was siehst du davon
ich gehe jetzt erstmal ein schönes steak
und dann nicht mehr im bett yes das ist
nämlich glaube ich kein auf dem server
jetzt gerade weil keiner da da können
wir natürlich super schlafen das ist der
vorteil wenn man allein auf dem server
ist siehst du das hat doch was positiv
ist dass du nicht da bist
hast du gerade geleistet
was ist gemacht jo jo alter als dann
klar keine klare und darf nicht an
als ein klassischer vertreter
alter
aber ich habe den direct date aber
scheißegal von hinten an dich ich bin
gegen eins gestorben und haben uns zwar
haben nicht
so eine rüstung gehabt ja okay danke
jungs konnten wir heute wahrscheinlich
auch nicht besonders viele level 0
1 5
ich muss echt nächsten tagen nicht
wirklich vor der noch gar kein alter
nein nein nein nein nein
wo kommen die alle her alter bekommen
diese scheiß wieder her what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] alter die sporen einfach interview
ich habe keine ahnung alter
alter
ich will doch einfach nur ein feld
machen mal gucken für mein schild noch
hat okay man spielt ist noch halbwegs in
ordnung halte ich höre man stellt damit
das leben gerettet klar konnte man
richtig viel schaden aber ich möchte aus
und stellt jetzt mal ja mach das mal
dass ich bester trick von eskimos mache
ich brauche genau du brauchst sieben
reisen
wir haben richtig viel eis in der truppe
ich weiß nicht weiß nicht wie sie darauf
ist so aber ich hoffe ja habe ich ja
schon ich habe ihn gefragt als nach zwei
minuten einmal gestorben bin
in der folge einfach perfekt und
ich sehe für mich
nicht
direkt darauf den sollte auf jeden fall
verwies im kula war gut dass wir in
unserer region haben ihr wisst
wüstenregion ftw für alle diese letzte
folge und ich mitbekommen haben ihr
müsst also ihr müssten nicht aber es war
geil wenn ihr ab jetzt immer und support
in den folgen zeigt an dem unter die
videos immer kommentiert mit herstellt
wüstenregionen
natürlich rover legionär wissen auch
alle dass die wüsten drohungen gemeint
ist
aber wie viele felder bewässert wasser
noch mal weizen
es wird so auf geändert 2 oder 4
ich glaub
ich
glaub ich meine schnelle reisen schon
ein bisschen schneller geht bisschen
zackiger damit die abonnenten ich sehe
ich war ziemlich sein
alter ja aber jetzt sehe ich gerade was
das hat mir auch an abonnent gezeigt
denn hier
klicken man kann sich einfach wurfsterne
machen ich mache immer 16
man kann sich aber wurfsterne macht es
einfach nur eisenwaren dar ein
wurfstern raus und wir haben echt mega
viel eisen der wünsche fast 100 einer
kiste
das ist das ist alles übel aber
so da ist die schärfe so dass man hier
die gräben weiter
für unser weizen weißt du eigentlich
auch der schnee zurück kommt wenn man
den weg macht und davon ob es schneit
kann geschneit ist in dem motto ja klar
in den abonnenten
so weit sind ein
kaputter richtig okay kein stoff dann
ist das gut wenn ich das kein problem
wir könnten eigentlich das passt das mal
machen das immer so hier wurde die hoch
dass die
hach ich muss erst was auch ein paar
euro dazu haben wir endlich weizen samen
hier ist endlich mal übrigens ich wusste
ich muss mir auf jeden fall erstmal an
keeper
alter
das ist auf jeden fall mehr gefährlich
dass das da oben direkt eine höhle ist
über unserem haus da laufen die ganzen
ich mache es wieder zu das ist übel
gefährlich
aber liebe gefährlich weg damit so ok ja
wir wollten uns einen einmal machen das
ging jetzt ein bisschen unter hier haben
wir genug eisen
wir uns ein
wenig behindert so dass oftmals gleich
mal drei mal die kann man dann nachher
wieder einpacken für alle anderen dazu
sollte sich kein problem sein und ja
wir machen ja auch was gemeinnütziges ne
wir machen hier ein fehlt sozusagen denn
viel
spaß
mache aber erst mal so ein drei mal drei
fällt damit wenn ich jetzt mal runter
laufen müssen damit wir uns hier
sozusagen das unendliche wasser haben
man kann jetzt nicht unser 3 x 3 fährt
voll direkt voll machen
soho
so dass sie alte mann braucht
theoretischen zwei wassereimer
jetzt eigentlich egal ob ist egal ob
wasser fließt zur bewässerung oder es
steht oder besser bestehen dass das ist
neu das passiert einfach
die frage ob fließt das wasser auch
begeistert oder stehen ist das weil sie
nicht ich also ich weiß dass ich immer
noch
das steht wir machen auf jeden fall mal
den ganzen schnee hier aus der umwelt
weil das ist direkt mal das wasser
gefroren auch dann wird
ja
einmal darum die es
irgendwie alt das wasser friert zu hier
ne
yo was ist das denn wieso freezers zu
aber wir wissen ja obwohl wir das machen
ja zb auch jetzt habe ich hier schon alt
naja ok gut dann schauen wir sind ein
bisschen spazieren minuten sportliche
zehn minuten dann machen jetzt die drei
einmal einfach voll die kann man ja
schön wenn das decken sagt sack und dann
bauen wir unser ding eben da hinten hin
und dann schreibe ich meine skype gruppe
dass jeder der zock einfach ein paar
weizen samen rhein setzt weißt du ja
aber wo können wir das fällt jetzt
hinmachen osterbrunnen mach das mal hier
hin
ach ja das gilt immer noch wenn
irgendwelche tipps sagt irgendwelche wer
hat zu tipps zu zu hierzu weiß welche
anmerkung oder dinge die wir besser
machen könnten oder irgendwelche special
tricks sowie diese schilder oder so dann
schreibt es auf jeden fall in die
kommentare das gerne das ist ultra
wichtig und das hilft nämlich extrem
viel wieder noch weniger werden können
das ist schon geil
und ja falls ihr welche themen habt über
die wir diskutieren könnten den nächsten
folgen könnt ihr auch einfach mal rein
schreiben irgendwelche fragen oder so
kommt vollkommen egal macht das was ich
aber
dingsda weizen wächst nicht auf sand
hier heute mal wieder ein dickes erde
fällt hier machten der
sportal.de höher was wir hier
machen ist mein erde fehlt
jetzt gerade wieder
gut aber für die bewässerung ist es egal
also der wasserkanal muss ja nicht aus
erde gemacht sagen
was nicht im computer club bläst
komplett egal also ich mach da die erde
einfach nur dahin wo die dann
letztendlich auch bepflanzt wird ja ja
genau den wasserkanal mache ich einfach
mal so hier an den rändern sohn
ach ja ihr könnt natürlich das ist ja
ganz bestimmt auch einfach mal die
kommentare schreiben wie viele felder
wasser bewässert so dass wir dann hier
unser dings optimieren können
wenn du mir der alte text erde ich habe
voll geil es genau das jetzt auch ist
richtig heiß
jetzt müssen wir noch die eu
ich mache mir das machen wir das auch
noch
ja ich glaube eine kann man noch machen
also noch eine frau würde ich meine hier
so noch eine reihe hast du noch nie ich
weiß nicht jeder
wissen emittieren
so die reihe machen jetzt auch fertig
sein partner wasser rein und schauen das
ganze
so ich habe hier in die wüste geparkt da
sollte nichts passieren
naja da machen wir ein schönes hier drei
mal drei feld wieder damit wieder etwas
wasser haben ja macht
sagt das hat echt geil man kann aus zwei
wasser einmal etwas wasser machen
das ist voll da
muss man in zwei blöcken abstand
platzieren die quellen damit die partie
kommt eigentlich auch schon ausprobieren
ganz einfach einmal schön aus dem
brunnenwasser neben der ist nun endlich
was war das schlecht
aus dem brunnen ja der ist nun endlich
wird ja klar natürlich wohnen geht
natürlich auch aber das ein bisschen
weiter weg
so das wasser fliesst
dann wird es wieder dunkel kann man
schlafen gehen dann weiterarbeiten
jetzt da es schon dunkel
ok
zurück du rückzug ins game und hoffen
dass uns keine motta fucking klarkommen
auf die angreifer die dinger sind echt
übel ne ich finde ich finde es toll hat
so ein starker mob kann einfach so
rumlaufen einen von hinten angreifen
ja das wird man das heißt es hat ist
halt echt er immer spannung drin weil
wenn solche fischer einen von hinten
angreifen können wenn wir jetzt nicht so
rüstungs mäßig so übt ist wie ich wie
kann ich glaube ich werde schon ganz gut
dabei loos schlaf doch
ich ging einfach gar nichts hier ich
kriege keine meldung you can only by the
night ihr steckt einfach nicht
wer was ist das denn
und es ist ganz klar nach draußen hast
du eine ahnung was es sein kann
ich nicht
liegt vielleicht daran ich habe meinem
bett genau in so eine nische gepackt die
zu recht daran
du kannst eigentlich da reinigen es muss
aber auch nachts seien aber jetzt jetzt
jetzt auf einmal her okay weil ich nach
dich im schlaf
johanna weiterhin gespannt
da habe ich ein zombie gehört den wollen
wir jetzt natürlich nicht
aber geil dass fabi vorgesorgt hat so
können uns jetzt ganz viel schiller an
den baum herum und dann würde ich sagen
kann wir demnächst auch mal in die eine
oder andere keine ahnung die pension
gehen weil es gibt hierbei wall street
so richtig für dimensionen
in dem man so verschiedene dinge holen
kann also so was wie der never oder ja
genau so läuft der hase
läuft über nicht ja klar du blödes 80
warum gibt es nicht eigentlich
alters und soto von daher finde ich
gerade wenn man sich so ein schönes
fehlt baut ja okay da ja okay ist
eigentlich egal wie weit es darunter
geht es einfach kein bock der jetzt muss
man das noch zu fixieren
ich bin gar nicht aber hier kommen die
ganze behindert bilden creeper und
acom jetzt stört da
so to get down
normalerweise braucht man drei jetzt
muss ich echt aufpassen müssen spieler
die nächsten
tage ist die zeit gekommen das fit zu
halten
also zwei felder bewässert dass ich auf
jeden fall ne
was hast du eigentlich so in den
nächsten folgen vor den nächsten folgen
haben
bis
anfang mai ein haus zu bauen und beim
verstehen jetzt auch in den server
installiert weil im singleplayer der
familie mit dem auslauf das einfach
nicht so schnell macht was für ein
family am ort der das richtig cool
werden entscheiden im singleplayer und
dem versuch hat in multiplayer reihen zu
packen genauso wie andere mods die
entscheidenden geplant sind zwei anderen
haushalt noch und die momentan da rein
zu patchen noch
okay ich habe gerade eben in der zeit
einen tintenfisch mit ninja wurfstern
gekillt mit spitzen nutzen information
doch ich hab sogar gesagt dass sowohl
axel graf ist geboten sie zieht die
messe gibt eine
gewisse wechselst du
wirst du sowieso und ich wäre wieder im
das müssen die un seien aber die ganze
zeit sehr schwierig ist eigentlich
seltsam wir sind wir sind die
wüstenregion und haben einfach unsere
unser vorläufiges haus zumindest in dem
eisbär ja das sagt jemand ich war schon
recht wie das ich überhaupt
webb hatte die unseren vorstellungen
entsprochen hat mit den entfernungen
vorher so weiter er hat ja alles extrem
viel arbeit diesen server aufzusetzen
und das hat der marius schon ganz gut
gemacht das ist schon ganz nah ist ja
ich wollte dir mach es noch nicht kennen
seinen link ist wie immer in der
beschreibung die x tekken schicken und
schicken was geht so
gib mir mal ein steak die ja ich habe so
ein bisschen hunger da gibt es im griff
ja da gibt es eine seite
brachen ein
das war einfach krass das war alles
radieschen hear what the [ __ ]
ja
es gibt radieschen
aber egal du kannst du bleiben ist kein
stress das ist
messi der per ski das spielend leicht
der ist natürlich auch eine beschreibung
unter den spielern der als links region
der der eis legen und lappen legion auch
genannt ja in diesem jahr sollte dies
richtig schläfer unsere stadt geben die
ist ja ich
halte ich finde einfach keinen ich finde
einfach keine weizen samir water
faktisch auch nicht portal das ist
voller marsch das ist
ja okay wir haben fast schon wieder 20
minuten voll ist krass wie schnell das
rom demokrat das übel nicht nur das so
schnell wahr gehabt jetzt gemacht die
jetzt ja ich habe jetzt zwei gemacht
dass jetzt die dritte folge wollte von
mir aber dann müsste ich eigentlich auf
dem level sein wie alle anderen auch
noch genau ich hab nämlich auch noch
zwei übrig also damit sehr
wahrscheinlich ist einfach nur überall
nur radieschen dass er von radieschen
warum dafür musst du sterben stirbt
ok jan heißt alles klar dann will ich
wieder zurück in meine bügel und wähnte
die aufnahme
soja leute ich hätte den anderen
bescheid sagen dass die ein bisschen
gras klären sollen das ein bisschen
pflanzen sollen und dann wenn wir in der
nächsten folge auf jeden fall bis zum
pvp sehen
beziehungsweise pvm weil wir erst mal
friedens phase haben mops töten können
vielleicht suchen was den einen oder
anderen dungeon und rasche natürlich wir
sind jetzt hier ganz gut geklappt mit
dem schild und so habe ich
nicht wissen und ihre herzen hasst dann
ist es schon möglich wenn wir ja auch
den aufnahmen angucken ein drittel
stellt auch ja aber macht nicht mehr
alles cool dann machen wir hier einen
quad wir beenden die folge sehen uns in
der nächsten folge wieder und ja ich
freue mich schon drauf ist bis zum geil
macht's gut und hart